one of the great burdens which our
romantic culture has imposed upon
long-term relationships is the idea that
love and sexual fulfillment must always
if things are working as they should
fits neatly together this beautiful and
hugely convenient idea raises a
passionate hope that over many years two
people will not only like and help one
another manage their domestic finances
reasonably well perhaps raise a family
have enjoyable holidays understand one
another's problems scheduled cleaning
routers put up with each other's
failings see each other's parents and
friends and pursue their careers in
harmony but they will also be devoted
and exciting sexual partners endlessly
in twining and recombining sometimes
being gentle and slow as others brutal
and urgent traveling together on a
shared lifelong erotic adventure it's
this sublime idea that begins to torment
us when as is the case in almost every
relationship sex starts with time to get
at once less intense and less frequent
more cautious and more frustrating more
adults with daily life and eventually
definitively more daunting as a prospect
than reading a book watching the news
together or simply going to sleep this
can appear nothing short of a
catastrophe a sign of a monstrous
failing and very often a prelude to a
breakup and yet the problem is not ours
alone it is simply that almost
everything that can make love go well
seems primed not to make sex go well and
vice-versa we are afflicted by a
fundamental misalignment in the
qualities of character and spirit
required by good sex on the one hand and
successful love on the other a
relationship cannot survive in the long
term without tenderness soberness
practical intelligence and selective
resignation we have to care
fully fathom another's motives explain
our moods overcome hurts and sulks and
assume a mantle of predictability sex on
the other hand in its most dramatic
thrilling versions demands that we be
heedless decadent perhaps cruel or
untenable submissive it can involve the
crudest language a moments of sublime
degradation in having to suffer from
feelings of inadequacy around what
happens in long-term love we other
victims of major cultural failure the
failure of our surrounding culture to
continually stress a realistic picture
of an unavoidable tension between two
crucial yet incompatible themes of
existence in a wiser world we would
collectively admit that the very rare
cases where love and sex did run
together were astonishing exceptions
with no relevance whatsoever to most of
our lives we would instead learn to pay
admiring attention to those who had
accepted with a reasonable show of
dignity and grace that the natural price
of long-term togetherness is a decline
in the quality and frequency of sexual
contact and that this is in a great many
cases a price very much worth paying
our sex book explores how sex truly
operates demonstrating that far from
thinking about sex too much we haven't
begun to think about it nearly enough